yeah we had to leave the strip because
of how windy it was and many Festival
goers left wondering what their next
move is going to be now that when we
were young Festival which was set to
take place today and tomorrow announced
its cancellation today emailing their
ticket holders even stating that those
who had tickets for tonight's show would
received a refund within 30 days we
spoke to those who had only planned on
attending one day and now with his
cancellation are forced to head back
home
I'm sad I mean like these are fans that
we've been wanting to listen to since we
were probably around like 12 years old
we knew it was gonna be
India we just didn't know it's going to
be this windy yeah and this is
definitely not what we were expecting
but
now some good news because of this
cancellation several Headliners of the
show have announced that they will be
performing for free at various venues
across town from The All-American
Rejects to Hawthorne Heights those are
just some of the artists that people
still can see now when we spoke to a lot
of people on the strip tonight many
speculating that there might be an
advance showing next weekend because of
the cancellations that's taken place
today but as for tomorrow that show is
still a go reporting near the strip
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now